MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Where am I?
ROBOT: Oh no, building
45 at Googleplex.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And
how did I get here?
ROBOT: Gosh, you tell me.
You just came here
and started speaking.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And
what are we going again?
ROBOT: Good gravy.
Presenting Google
Play Services 7.3.
Get to work.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's right.
Welcome to release 7.3
of Google Play Services.
And as usual, we've packed
it with lots of new features
that will allow you
to build better apps,
because that's what
this is all about.
And big announcement for wear
is that you can now connect
multiple wearables to a phone.
Let's check that out.
I can't decide which wearable
I'm going to wear today.
I kind of like that black one.
But that one is better
if I'm going jogging.
Heck, I can't decide.
They're all so nice.
Hot dog, since I have Google
Play Services 7.3 installed,
I can wear them all
at the same time!
So this capability
allows you to create
a network of wearable nodes,
all connected to single phone.
And since they can be
more than two nodes,
we are introducing the Channel
API in the wear data API.
Which allows you to send large
files, or even stream data,
between two individual nodes.
But how would you
know which node
you should communicate with?
For example, if you wanted
to download something.
That's the job of
the new Capability
API, which allows your app to
locate node supporting a given
capability over to the many
new things in Google Fit.
Many things in life are
not based on a daily cycle.
For example, the work week,
the tax year, or a new year.
Fitness, however,
is all about today,
like how many steps
have you taken today?
How many calories have you
put in your body today?
How many push ups
have you done today?
So to make these
today things easier,
the History API now
provides this method.
readDailyTotal, which aggregates
data for a given data type
from midnight to the
current time of day.
So you just put in
the data type there,
and then it returns
to daily total.
For example, how many
steps have I taken today?
And since everyone's
always talking
about how many steps
everyone's taken every day,
the TYPE_STEP_COUNT_DELTA
data type
can now be queried by
all apps on all devices
without requiring
any authentication.
But fitness is not
only about activity.
It is also about what
you put into the body.
So therefore,
nutrition data types
have been added, enabling
you to record things
like protein, fat, cholesterol,
sodium, you name it.
Turning to location where you
now specify a maximum wait
time for location updates,
which enables the system
to batch location
updates together
to reduce battery consumption.
And remember, the
location settings
dialog we introduced
in the last release?
Well, in addition
to location updates,
it is now also possible
to get notified
when location settings are
changing by getting location
availability up dates.
This release also
has enhancement
to the common package where
a Google API client now
allows you to add optional APIs
through the addApiIfAvailable.
So if you previously had to
have multiple connections
flow for the phone and
the wearable, for example,
you can now use this feature
to simplify your code.
And that's it for this time.
But check out these
resources to get the details.
And remember,
Google Play Services
enables you to
build better apps.
And now it's your turn to
go out there and create
these great apps.
And don't forget to
tell us all about.